plus l'échéance du déconfinement se
rapproche plus le brouillard épais sur
notre avenir s'estompe petit à petit à
seulement deux mois des congés d'été
l'avenir de nos vacances au soleil
semble plus que jamais compromis mais si
le gouvernement avait prévenu que les
voyages à l'étranger serait impossible
voici à quoi devrait ressembler notre
été c'est le secrétaire d'état chargé du
tourisme jean baptiste lemoyne qui a
fait plusieurs annonces concernant ce
que nous pourrons faire ou non durant la
période de juillet-août si cette semaine
edouard philippe a annoncé qu'après le
11 mai il sera toujours impossible se
déplacer à plus de 100 kilomètres de son
domicile sauf dérogation cette
interdiction ne sera visiblement pas
levé avant l'été le tourisme ne pourra
reprendre que de façon concentrique
dans un premier temps avec une clientèle
je dirais d'ultra proximité et on le
voit avec un certain nombre de sites qui
vont pouvoir rouvrir vous l'avez compris
cet été les vacances seront au coin de
votre rue
un été qui s'annonce compliqué puisqu'on
ne sait pas encore ce qu'il sera
possible ou non de faire l'état n'a pas
encore statué sur la réouverture des
hôtels et locations de vacances et les
bars et les restaurants ses fins mais
que le gouvernement décidera ou non de
la réouverture de ces établissements de
bouche pour le 2 juin en fonction de la
situation à ce moment précis en
attendant en allant faire vos courses
dans votre rue dites vous que vous êtes
peut être déjà arrivé sur votre lieu de
vacances
alors très bien ça très drôle le sujet
les souffrances et de repartir en
vacances près de chez nous cet été est
ce que vous êtes pour est ce que vous
êtes content géraldine maillet ma chérie
je suis d'abord pour respecter les
règles respectées ce qu'on va nous dire
je pense que toutes les work in progress
est à dire que la vérité d'aujourd'hui
ne sera pas celle de jeudi prochain et
encore moins dans deux mois presque oui
je me connaissent au jour d'aujourd'hui
c'est d'euros voir ma grand-mère de
revoir ma mère qu'elle soit en bonne
santé et je pense que ça sera
effectivement dans un périmètre de bain
paris voilà c'est tout et c'est comme ça
il faut penser aussi qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui vont juste à pouvoir partir
en vacances non pas pour des raisons
c'est n'être sanyo pour des raisons
économiques et avant tout voilà alors
d'accord vous en faites vous voulez
boire votre mère votre grand-mère et
nous vous en avez rien à [ __ ] homme
n'est pas du tourisme en ouganda
quand même terriblement bien merci merci
oui gilles verdez le tourisme en france
on est la première le premier pays
touristique au monde
mais le tourisme en france et 2 millions
d'emplois donc moi je suis pour que ce
soit dans un rayon de 100 kilomètres
mais que ce soit officialisé
qu'on nous dise pas vous verrez la
semaine prochaine dans quinze jours ou
dans un mois qu'on dise maintenant vous
pourrez partir ceux qui le peuvent dans
un rayon d'espoir de la coque sa vie qui
vont mourir pour toi comme ça mais non
tu fasses gilles je t'aime beaucoup mais
comment tu veux qu'ils fassent ils
savent même pas ce qui va et ce qui va
arriver dans un mois dans deux mois
comment tu veux te où tu vas partir en
vacances et dans quel périmètre c'est
n'importe quoi
genius moi c'est ce qu'a dit le
secrétaire d'état 100 km si on
officialise ça comme ça on peut savoir
et encore l'oit au sprint ils ne peuvent
pas savoir encore il essaie d'aller le
plus loin possible pour essayer
peut-être d'avoir des bonnes nouvelles
le plus positif savent pas ils savent
pas si le virus va pas disparaître avec
la saison salle toi si si on va trouver
des trucs non mais donc j'ai dit pendant
beaucoup d'incisions maintenant si
aujourd'hui vous d'ici à 100 km et que
en août vous voyez qu'en fait et ben y'a
plus rien et que tous les autres pays du
monde la veille par dans tous les autres
pays arabes à waimes et nous on a 100 km
ne dit pas de bêtise
on va pas condamner d'ores et déjà un
oui qui totalement sinistré là c'est ça
la vie au jour le jour heure par heure
là pour l'instant on nous dit 100 km
parce que pour l'instant on imagine que
100 km ça va pas non plus au delà de
notre département
après si demain les études et les
écologistes disent qu'on peut aller au
delà de m on ira au delà
mais pour l'instant on navigue on
navigue à vue et moi je trouve pas qu'on
me dise pour l'instant 100 km et on
verra demain on va sinistrés déjà à
l'agonie
bien sûr tout de suite que c'est fini
que c'est mort assez catastrophique
alors regardez ce qu'a dit la porte
parole du gouvernement si bête ndiaye
sur les vacances d'été regarder à nos
concitoyens
apprenez tranquillement une location à
l'autre bout de la france par rapport à
là où vous habitez et soyez tranquille
vous pourrez y aller si malheureusement
on avait une deuxième vague épidémique
ou si on avait des foyers épidémiques
ces femmes le cluster qui se développait
évidemment il faudrait prendre des
mesures plus restrictives que celles que
on aura dans le temps du déconfinement
vraiment en vos tuerie qu'est ce t'en
penses non ma jeu en ce mois là j'ai
entendu rené qui dit on navigue à vue
c'est vrai que pour l'instant on avance
a vu tu peux pas aujourd'hui annoncé des
trucs de kilométrage
il faut attendre le 2 juin savoir s'ils
commencent à avancer comme a dit
géraldine comment va avancer vers berck
déconfinement parce qu'aujourd'hui je
vous donne un exemple si tu entends
apolitique qui peut dit vous pouvez
aller en vacances à 100 km au tour chez
toi ok habite à dunkerque à la lance en
vacances jamais de la vie j'habite à
paris iii en vacances avec tous les jeux
pour les là j'attends moi je suis
normalement sahraouis 100 km autant dire
reste chez toi et autant de savoir
l'économie de l'hôtellerie elle est
plombée
alors toi vraie montée pour ou contre
comparé près de chez soi
têtu et moi je dis qu'il ya plusieurs
cas par exemple je te donne un cas il ya
des gens qui sont aisés condé résidence
secondaire il ya des gens condé de la
famille dans le sud de la france
si tu pars à 4 dans ta voiture et que tu
fais 600 bornes pour aller dans une
maison chez quelqu'un en sécurité dans
sa maison où tu es ou bien des gens
les débuts une maison à plusieurs en
quoi ça se dérangent qu'ils fassent 600
kilomètres dans sa voiture pour aller
dans une maison avec une piscine parce
qu'il en a marre de son appartement
peu importe je dis maisons une piscine
et puis il ya aussi ce qu'on reparle
argent de partir malheur aux maris sera
chiant ce sera sur paris
il va y avoir des drames économiques on
l'a dit mais il ne faut pas avancer
avant les choses qu'on va mettre la
charrue avant les boeufs d'abord le 2
juin et après on voit comment en avant
explique les deux dire aujourd'hui
le premier est une sorte d autant plus
le maître qui habite à dieppe il va pas
partir je vais juste à côté de celle
minuterie alors venu et diaby touba la
mer ni celui bien sûr il ya quelqu'un
qu'on aime beaucoup et qu'on reçoit
souvent ici c'est jean paul hamon
président de la fédération des médecins
de france
il a poussé un petit coup de gueule hier
soir sur bfm tv regardez ce qui va se
passer pour les français avec cette
histoire de vacances regarde je peux
vous dire que le confinement durée
sévères comme il est actuellement les
gens on va on va avoir plus de déprimer
de et de suicides que que de que de
trucs de covin les gens vont pas
supporter ça alors je pense sincèrement
qu'il faut lever le couvercle de temps
en temps quand je vois que les parcs
dans les grandes agglomérations sont
fermés que les forêts les forêts sont
fermés que les plages sont interdites
alors que on pourrait très bien sur une
plage d'un kilomètre on pourrait très
bien dire on met 500 personnes sur la
plage pendant deux heures
en bretagne c'est bien vous allez pas
resté deux heures dans la flotte donc il
ya un moment donné vous faut donner un
petit peu d'air intelligemment
alors jean paul hamon qu'on adore un
sursis à donner son avis benjamin
castaldi là dessus moi je pense qu
nettement comme comme comme effective on
ne sait pas grand chose
c'est pas très malin je trouve bien
maintenant aux gens que moi de vue au
mois d'août ils iront à 122 ch et je
trouve que en terme de com une fois de
plus intelligent
maintenant les français prouve qu'on ne
sait pas ce qui a été dit pour l'instant
pour l'instant mais non mais non c'est
ce que voudrait que dis-je il donc âge
il ne fait pas partie du gouvernement
mon chéri non mais lalinde je pense que
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on ne sait pas
et comme les français ont prouvé qu'ils
étaient capables de respecter les règles
si on nous dit de ne pas bouger je pense
qu'on ne voudra pas maintenant nous dire
aujourd'hui effectivement qu'on va pas
bouger c'était pas bon nous le dire
parce que les gens ont besoin
effectivement comme la ligne monsieur un
peu
appel d'air et voix et d'espoir qu'on
peut relâcher la pression sur les gens
c'est ce que je alors regardé france et
n'ont pas l'air comme des fous à l'idée
de partir en vacances près de chez eux
regardez petit micro photo un terme en
falloir trouver une solution parce que
quoi qu'il arrive sinon sa rentrée n'est
que ben y'en a qui vont ils voient
qu'ils vont dépasser 100 km quoi qu'il
arrive c'est une bonne occasion de
visiter le coin je dirais il ya
tellement de belles choses à voir même
dans même dans le coin priorité c'est la
santé de tout
on va s'y plier décret va s'y plier bâle
ville qu'elle stoppe pas est ce que tu
penses qu'ils étudient cette idée de
partir en vacances à côté de chez soi ça
te dirait moi ça me fait doucement
rigoler parce que quand tu prends tout
le littoral méditerranéen le littoral
atlantique là le maître hitchcock
facture atteint cote qui vont se
retrouver à face sur les plages du
commun qui va le gérer ça j'apprenais
cardiologue d'aller plus de 5 km le mec
à paris on me disait raymond tout à
l'heure dans le code de route qui peut
aller jusqu'à verdun marveaux lacombe
est cité balnéaire
il n'y a pas un qui a mieux carrément
alors pas comment on peut le dire à
quelques 6 tab à 5 km au mec qui va à
narbonne plage où je la côte atlantique
et lorsque tu peux tu veux pas les
attaques kg plus de 20 km mais il arrive
pour cent kilomètres c'est pour l'autre
mais c'est pas pour les assurances pour
le 11 mai c'est paul 11 mais la voilà
vous plaît vous faites là vous êtes hors
sujet les chefs je trouve qu'à les
regarder les tweets sur les vacances
voilà qui ont été très drôle
bien sûr il ya plein de trucs qui sont
sortis il y en a qui pensent que mon
devoir prendre un ticket pour aller se
baigner comme à la poste
regardez
numéro regard des numéros 249 merci
voilà regarder d'autres ont trouvé de
belles destinations en france regardez
singapour qu'aucun los angeles et new
york voilà des vacances dorées un peu
mais bon il y en a aussi qui refuse
totalement de croire à cette info
regardez tweet on va la regarder
regardez cette vidéo regardez on s'en
remet en grève non c'est faux c'est fou
j'ai pas caché la noce mais c'est faux
c'est quoi ce qui permettra à comcast et
ses conséquences au regard des autres
petites vidéos quand on va goûter aux
vacances à côté de la maison regarder
prem's les boulonnais et enfin c'est
vrai que le bruit de la mer de l'océan
va nous manquer donc certains ont trouvé
la solution
regardez ça c'était sûr tik tok regarder
ça
ça fait en plus ça fait du bien
franchement ça ça va bien et regarder et
enfin quand je vois que mes vacances
d'été sont annulés regardez la tête
qu'on va tous faire voilà c'est bien sûr
la tête de jean luc mélenchon regardez
ces journées retrouve à savoir d'été
sont annulés voilà merci
voilà voilà avec sa petite sacoche jean
luc mélenchon a estimé t on va voir pour
oh qu'est ce que vous en pensez
oui qu'est ce que vous en pensez si vous
pouvez voir la wii géraldine vous savez
que par exemple en espagne et ce entre
un plancher justement sur comment on va
pouvoir accéder aux plages alors des
créneaux horaires avec par exemple un
tour donateurs de créneaux de rotation à
l'enfant a droit à une oeuvre de plage
par jour par famille par exemple
d'accord non mais imaginez des
séparations entre les familles en fait
on est sans doute on est en train de
réaménager la plage différemment pour
cet été un peu exceptionnel voilà